yeah really if you guys are at a
restaurant and let's say uh
there's kids running around being very
belligerent parents aren't doing
anything
at that point do you say something to
the parents
to the kids or do you just keep shut
what do you mean
so there's kids that are at a table next
you keep bumping into you're eating at a
restaurant they're
knocking things over they're screaming
they're yelling parents are talking to
their friends
do you just sit there yes see why in
that situation
because because that's that's what i
hate
my brother and i were at um
you're gonna hate this place but we were
at el cholo el solo
oh the mexican restaurant yeah yeah on
six hey i respect the history of el
cholo
i just i'm not sold on the food is that
an okay compromise for you
i love i love the food because i think
it's very historic i think that i love
the food i love the food
it's just not my jam it's like there's
so many awesome mexican places i
understand that baby mom and pop shop
but they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] chimichangas chimichanga the
chicken chicken chunks are the best on
planet earth
they are they're very good the shredded
tinga chicken i love it
my brother and i were eating chinga
chicken chicken
and when my brother and i we talk like
you know sailors
sure [ __ ] that guy you know we just you
know and we had
a lady come up to her at the table and
go
excuse me will you not you know
use that profanity my grandchildren are
here
and my brother and i go sorry and we
just whispered the whole way
but no more i'm no longer doing that
anymore that's why
i proposed that situation say the kids
are next to you bumping into you
at the point where they're knocking down
your glasses see like
swish it around why wouldn't you tell
them like hey kids sit the [ __ ] down
like because because i i i think my
point of view is
you know when you're at a table in a
restaurant
regardless of what's happening just mind
your own [ __ ] business
i agree with bobby because in my head
the reason i would never say anything
it's like
you know what it's hard enough to have
kids it's the same reason why i don't
say anything and i
grin and bear when like a child is
kicking the back of my seat in an
airplane for 17 hours like one time
on a flight to melbourne um it was like
a 15 hour flight right
there was not only a crying kid like a
toddler just straight up kicking my back
the whole way through but the woman on
the aisle seat was about
350 pounds so i couldn't get up to pee
so i politely told her that i was just
like don't worry about it i'm just gonna
crawl over you each time it was the
worst flight of my life
but i just don't say anything because i
always just imagine it's probably harder
for the parent back there and it's
probably harder for the woman next to me
like
i'm young i'm fine nothing's really
happening
and i just really kind of like it's it
doesn't it bothers me
but probably not as much as their body
bothered the parents
the parents you know so i'm just like
whatever kids like that's the one thing
that i love about the philippines that
i have a fear of raising kids here
versus raising them in the philippines
because there's so much like shame and
rules
when it comes to parenting here like in
the philippines
like your kid could be screaming just
being a kid
and then there are no repercussions over
here it's like
you know silence your child like take
control of your child
and it's like it's a [ __ ] one and a
half year old man like
yeah but what if in the philippines i've
seen this where a mother
is dragging you know i mean their child
by their hair
across you know a target right
yeah it is at that point at that point
do i
at that point do i say you know excuse
me don't drag your child by your hair
or do we mind our own business there no
if a child is being harmed and abused
and like
no i would absolutely intervene i'd be
like what the [ __ ] lady that's a kid
i would say something then i'd be like
what what the [ __ ] are you doing i'm
gonna call somebody if you don't stop
doing that
yeah but i don't think i would do that i
would that's [ __ ] up if you're not
gonna go help a child who's obviously
being harmed in that way
and but but you know what there have
been situations legitimately
where like it's not our place okay let
me give you a scenario
make it good i think it's gonna be very
good let me throw it to you gilbert cool
you're at a restaurant by yourself
and you see a friend of yours let's call
him
tommy g